hey hey we'll get right kitty you
deserve it it will get you to hell you
will burn it engage just don't now was
he just trying to eat the Koran now I've
seen some crazy things but now you know
when somebody's really doing some
foolish stuff like that how do we
respond this guy just really hungry for
Islam or he's trying to provoke you and
we have all sorts of extremists out
there so how do we now when somebody is
really trying to push you to the limits
how should we as peaceful human beings
because that's what's this way of life
calls us to to have peace with our
Creator peace with front ourselves and
people society obviously this extremist
he don't want peace he wants trouble so
we're going to be giving you some tips
and some advice on how to handle
yourself in these situations we'll be
right back this is the
[Music]
this is the please be with you welcome
to the D Shah Salaam Aleichem how are
you brother wiley gonna slam when I'm at
the lair but I got to allgor but
alhamdulillah all the way from RZ from
Australia beautiful house everybody back
there very good over there do they got
people trying to eat the Quran not yet
not yet we got some crazy stuff going on
in America it happens it happens you
obviously got cedar video it was very
disturbing to see something like that
definitely what are your first thoughts
point number one it just reflects a very
bad impression of a society where we are
it just you know shows to us there is
extremists on all corners of the world
it's a very ugly face for any society
any community any country I don't want
you to get a bad impression we got some
very good Christians out there you know
very sympathetic to a lot of the
justices that are going towards the
Muslims you know Muslims are if you see
obviously the most persecuted the you
know the most misunderstood Islam but
you have a lot of good Christians but
then you got some of these extreme
elements out there yep so I don't want
you to you know be kind of that
yeah picture well I'm us on your trip
here true just a few confessions in
Australians in general don't like
Americans a lot maybe just because of
the accent but things like this doesn't
really add up yeah things like this
really reflects a very bad you know face
of any society you might be seeing
similar pictures coming from Australia
sometimes and just imagine what you're
looking from outside just throws in a
very bad image so here the Deen show we
want to keep things fair and balanced
definitely we want to address some
things that you saw in the video and one
of the things now is the respect that we
have for other people's religions and
their books can you talk about this show
point number one dollar allah subhanaw
taala mentions in the koran directly
especially in surah anaam surah number 6
i number 108 allah subhanaw taala says
not the gods whom they believe in so
allah subhanallah makes it absolutely
clear in Islam that as a Muslim you
cannot you should not abuse other gods
even though Islam is the monotheistic
religion and you believe any other God
who's associated with the one true God
is a major sin in the religion but
Almighty God Allah says don't abuse
other gods in in extension of that to
abuse other religions in extension of
that don't abuse other people so this is
very very clear in Islam so as a Muslim
I would respect all other faiths and
especially Judaism and Christianity are
the religions of the religion of the
books from God as a Muslim allah
subhanho wa taala teacher says in the
quran ya al al khattab say to them as
people of the book with respect so we
respect those people out there from
other faiths now doesn't seem like these
extremists here like you have much
respect show as in any society you will
always have people on both ends you will
have people who are good you'll have
some people who are bad just reflecting
back with Australia a few years back I
don't know if you heard some
international Indian students were
brutally abused and even killed by some
bad Australians is that Australia
definitely not but you'll have extremist
elements in every society and this is
one of the extremist elements from maybe
the Christian society now how does this
go we know that one came to Jesus peace
be upon him who we love and revere is
one of the mightiest messages yeah no
Muslim is most obviously unless he
believes and love Jesus yes
now one came to them and you can
probably expand on this and ask them oh
good master what good thing can I do to
have eternal life jesus said why you
calling me good there's only one good
but God and if one wants to enter into
paradise eternal life got to keep the
commandments the one I want to focus on
is loving your neighbor very true it's
just lovely in a river it's really
confronting the words that you just
quoted from the Bible is the passage
mentioned in Gospel of Matthew chapter
19 verses 16 and 17 and it's an amazing
story it's an amazing teaching where a
person comes to Jesus as you mentioned
he says good master what good thing
shall I do to enter eternal life and all
he says is keep the commandments and we
know the first 10 most important
Commandments and one of that is love
your neighbor how could you be so
confronting so abusive towards a fellow
being
towards a fellow-countryman towards a
person from from your own society so
this is not really reflecting any
religion you know I say to people like
this you are actually damaging your own
cause you're damaging your own fate
you're damaging your own religion and
community we're doing that because if
you really want to you know win the
hearts of people who you want them to
come over you want it cuz he's another
thing they were saying is like you're
going to hell you're damned to hell I
mean Jesus and all the prophets came to
save people from going to hell that's
right exactly yes you know this this
approach sometimes this is you know
human community has has this different
approaches within the you know attitude
we should have empathy towards each
other and that's what Jesus and Prophet
Muhammad peace be upon but of them
taught to the people to have empathy for
example Abu jahil if you ask any Muslim
who is Abu jahil the Prophet would say
the people would say he was the worst
enemy of Prophet Mohammed okay
he's abusing him blaspheming him making
plans to kill him
murder him but you know what Prophet
Muhammad does he wakes up in the middle
of the night that is the time of the
Hajj hood stands up in front of Allah
next to her yeah Allah oh my god give
guidance to Abu jahil amazing and you
know what is guidance it's like you're
praying to God let him walk with me in
paradise the one who's abusing you
blaspheming you killing you you're
making prayer to God let him work with
me that's the attitude you got to have
empathy you know save people not throw
them into the Hellfire
we're not the judges here and that's
what Jesus said you're not the judge you
remember the story when the people were
pelting stone to earth to a woman and
Jesus said to them threw a stone if you
are sinless and everyone had to walk
away that's all we all are sinners so
you shouldn't really be judging each
other and that approach was very very
bad from that person when we come back
from the break I want to ask you again
back on the health in condemning people
to hell get because the Bible's clear on
some things Bible's clear on forbidding
alcohol he's right on yet forbidding
pork I'm forbidding sodomy treating many
other things yes but where can someone
get the evidence to go ahead and condemn
the Muslims to the Hellfire yes I want
explicit statements is there anything
saying if such as judge you don't
believe in Jesus that he's God's Son of
God he died for your sins
but you're going to hell can you answer
this definitely many will consider you a
sum of a Christian would you say Bible
scholar Christian scholar you start in
studying this coming from the chain of
apathy that and his a studentship
obviously that is my expertise and
that's my field of education so we got
the person who's well versed in the
Bible and expert in it we're going to be
asking these really tough questions here
in the D show so don't go anywhere
ladies and gentlemen this is your
captain speaking
welcome aboard flight five two three
five non-stop to London Heathrow the
temperature is 25 degrees outside and we
are expecting a fairly smooth flight
today in a few moments the flight
attendants will be passing around the
cabin to offer you hot and cold drinks
we thank you for choosing to fly with us
today and we hope you enjoy your flight
thank God it was just a dream
god I don't believe in God ladies and
gentlemen the captain has turned on the
fasten seatbelt sign
we need of Ashiya who mojo Kahuna Neeta
Lulla homoplasy Nana who Dean
you
please subscribe to the video follow us
on our official Facebook and Twitter
pages in the links below
please also help support the V show by
making a donation in the link below back
here on the D show with our special
guests all the way from Australia
hamdullah thank you for being with us
we're going to go right back to that
clip again we'll get right kitty you
deserve it it will get you to hell you
will burn just don't okay so now people
who are just tuning in didn't catch the
first part they know what we're talking
about we're talking about this young man
obviously I don't know if he's he's seen
like just deranged lunatic or something
he's really trying to provoke you know
the students there are going to study
you know last thing they're expecting
this lunatic eat trying to eat the Quran
so before the break we talked about our
respect for other religions I respect
and you quoted a verse from the rating
Word of God and now I want to ask you
kept saying hell hell you're going to
hell you going to hell this nap can you
tell me you speak a lot with different
Christians and whatnot and what evidence
do they use to provide to say that now
you as a Muslim are going to help show
the point number one generally the
people who believe in different
religions they all have this concept
that people of that faith are going to
go to paradise the people who reject
that faith will not go to paradise but
let's put it into perspective according
to the Bible the Bible does not say any
way that Christianity is the religion of
God the word Christianity does not exist
in the Bible at all it's interesting
what Christianity means according to
Oxford Dictionary is a person who
believes in Jesus Christ and his
teachings and the concept that he is the
son of God but if you put all of this
together point over one who believes in
Jesus Christ as a Muslim
I have obligated to believe in Jesus
peace be upon him in fact no Muslim is a
Muslim if he or she does not believe in
Jesus Christ peace be upon him so as a
Muslim I am technically according to
Oxford Dictionary a Christian so how
could I go to Hellfire when I believe in
Christ when I love Christ and when I
follow Christ so a true Christian who
says if you can't go to hell if you're
going to go to Hellfire it has to be you
reject Christ but someone who believes
in Christ is the last person to enter
Hellfire in that sense so Muslims should
not be said that we will go to the
Hellfire now many of the guys they they
have in the banners and the shirts John
3:16 for God so loved the world that He
sent His only begotten Son whoever
believes in him and what not so can we
say now if you dissect this verse ok
can you go into it because hazardous
this word begotten hasn't by the highest
eminence of scholars been thrown out
very right so if you look at the Bible
no Bible has had its revisions one of
the earliest English language or English
version of the Bible was you know the
King James Version published in 1611
Christian era that has this word goes
this words Gospel of John chapter 3
verse 16 which says God so loved the
world that He gave His only begotten Son
now this title begotten has been removed
overthrown put out from the Bible in the
New International Version and in the
revised version of the Bible so what
happens here is the Christian scholars
understood that this word does not exist
in the original text no once you remove
that what happens here is jesus is son
of God according to Bible in various
places
Adam is son of God David is son of God
you know other prophets are sons of God
it specifically says in one place in
book of Romans chapter 8 verse 16 it
says for anyone who follows God is son
of God if you bring it back to the
Arabic terminology that means our Abid
the one who believes in God obeys God
and follows God so in in context in the
Bible everyone is a son of God who
believes and works for God it's like you
know when I come to America some of the
elderly people they saw me they saw my
son I thought it's an American thing you
know my son does not mean I'm actually
his son literally but what it means is
it's a it's a term
respect for the society the Americans
respect young people so there's a my son
similarly God is saying to everyone in
the Bible you're my son because God
cares for you that's the language but
the moment someone says this is literal
then God's got sons in tongues in the
Bible
everyone's a son yeah yes so now if you
take it how it's supposed to be
translated a Jew no the Jewish know the
language gather the Semitic language
they didn't take it as a little second
innate and they took it as a servant of
God very true a servant so we would fit
in this dead we believe in him as a
servant of God we don't reject him yes
we can't go to the Hellfire definitely
exactly vide rule you just added it
together all right it's amazing going
along and we're going to come to the the
main point of dealing with this satanic
spirit of okay this provocation hobbies
is going on another thing that's thrown
out there is he kept insulting the last
and final messenger who was a true
brother to Jesus Moses Abraham Mohammed
peace be upon he kept calling him a
pedophile yes now how do we relate to
that is see people some people use this
as a blasphemy against Islam and Prophet
Muhammad sallallaahu later seldom
abusing now this is one of the ways
Islamophobic bigots sometimes because
they don't have rational arguments to
put forward they subscribe to abusive
and hateful terminology if someone is
really sincere about his approach or her
approach you got a question about it you
deal with the scholarship you go to the
people and ask if I've got a concern
about Americans and as I said right in
the beginning some Australians don't
really like Americans I wanted to find
out why and when I did my research I
just found it's only because of heavy
American accent I tell you what you
would have the same experience with me
coming from Australia I would have a
different exit so it's all about
diversity not really abusing each other
similarly people abuse Islam and Prophet
Mohammed because there is a very strong
Lobby against it just quoting you one
article from Times magazine dated 16th
of April 1979 it says more than 60,000
books were written against Islam and
Prophet Muhammad from 1800 to 1950 a
span 150 years sixty thousand books you
do a quick calculation more than a book
a day when printing was not even a
commercial business then so it just
shows that there's people who are
writing so much against the salmon
Muslims not coming to the actual
question pedophilia the reason they
claim that
they say Prophet Muhammad peace be upon
him married I shadowed the Allah and had
the mother of the believers when she was
nine now let's take this into
perspective so what is the right age of
marriage then so people say 18 well I
was just in Dallas Texas I was told the
age of married is fourteen ma'am where's
that in Texas in Texas
yeah you go you go to the Christianity
and I've found from Christian
encyclopedia it says the age of mother
Mary the mother of son of God Jesus was
twelve twelve years old well years old
and according to some Auto Doc's
Christians she was 11 years old so
mother Mary 11 years old mother I should
9 years old elder sister younger sister
not a big deal right you come in
Australia the youngest mother was 11
years old in America I can assure you go
to the maternity hospital you'll find 11
year old Americans becoming women
mothers the government supports them so
you can become a mother but you can't
marry in Islam we believe in discipline
we believe in being organized we believe
in legality you want Muslims wouldn't
really be speeding on the streets they
do here I'm sure they do but I'm saying
in general Muslims shouldn't be breaking
the laws now that also what happens here
is they shouldn't be so coming back to
the marriage of Prophet Muhammad a nice
shot of the 11 huh
point number one no according to
community everywhere there are different
ages of marriage in Texas 14 in
Australia 18 in India 21 for the men I
heard in Massachusetts is still on the
books 12 years old amazing see and in
Australia in India 21 I have to suffer
three more years so every different
country would have difference so
according to Indians Americans are going
to be pedophiles all Americans marrying
under 21 according to Australia's all
Americans are going to be pedophile
because they all married under 18 right
so what you need to see is look things
into context at the time of the Prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him the law
according to Judaism Christianity Islam
and the non-muslims was you can marry at
any age according to medical science
journal a man or a woman when they reach
the age of puberty they can marry so
slum believes in freedom of expression
and freedom for every person she is
ready for marriage at 9 she's a grownup
woman she is a mature woman she chose to
marry Prophet Muhammad agreed to marry
and and the counselor led the marriage
what what should it bother anyone else
it's a perfect marriage correct marriage
legal marriage so you can't if you take
it back you can have prosecute someone
at 1400 years ago
for the society didn't object the family
didn't object the religious law didn't
object nobody not even those enemies
brought any kind of yes and not
exactly not just 4980 so even right now
you got now you get some existence in
Massachusetts and America and Australia
anyone what different law so just
because Americans marry you at 14 the
Indians can't call them pedophiles right
we're gonna we're going to come back we
go to break it more on this very very
important topic here today show don't go
anywhere did you know that part of a
being a Muslim that we have to believe
in Jesus peace be upon him and a Muslim
was not a Muslim here does not believe
in Jesus do you know that God had
mentioned Jesus peace be upon him in the
Quran 25 times verses
he only mentioned Mohammed we step on
him only five times do you know that the
most honorable woman in Islam was Mary
the mother of Jesus peace be upon him do
you know that Mary was mentioned in the
Bible only eighteen times and in the
Quran she was mentioned thirty-two times
almost 100 percent more do you know that
in the Quran God have dedicated a whole
chapter for the mother of Jesus Surat
Maryam or chapter of Mary also do you
know that God have dedicated a whole
chapter in the Quran to talk about the
Last Supper surah al-maida do you know
that the most number of people named
Jesus worldwide were Muslims this is
Jesus peace be upon him in Islam we
honor him we respect him it is our role
model please subscribe to the DCO follow
us on our official Facebook and Twitter
pages in the links below
please also help support the D show by
making a donation in the link below back
here on the D show and obviously it's
clear you have to if you're going to
marry you have to abide by the law to
land yes that's clear we're giving
examples now right now they're seeing
some academics and you have people who
have written on this topic you can see
that you know even the founding fathers
you know of this country nobody would
consider them pedophiles but you know
the ones who laid down the law prior to
1886 you know the age was about 6-7
Delaware is actually seven years old you
know nobody would consider them
pedophile so how do people have the
audacity you mentioned Mary's Jesus's
mother Mary piece of according to
Universal in Cyprus idiot yeah Christian
encyclopedia she was 12
eleven right so we mentioned now real
important
you can object to what a spiritual
reason religious reason cultural reason
you have no leg to stand out exactly and
she wasn't she engaged to be married
even before the Prophet peace like her
father also the parents nobody was was
rejected it was lost enemies of the time
did not reject they didn't irritating
given rejected now most go ahead because
that was the norm of the society and
that is a still the norm of to society
in different places at all and I said
sometimes when these people they object
they fail to realize their objection is
even against them because they're saying
Marlo is a better law but you lower
differs in different states for twelve
to fourteen to eighteen to India
twenty-one so everyone's pitiful
according to everyone else's definition
but God's Way yes obviously is now the
woman has reached maturity as far as she
can give birth to a child yes okay and
then someone says what about the
maturity level exactly can you compare a
mature level back woman back then to
today obvious yes it C and Wyman is
different places different time is
different but even with that respect if
we put it all in all all in one place
take it this way the Mexican people they
said to the government they said we want
of a woman to marry at fourteen they
said no no you can't get mature woman at
that age they said now a woman at
fourteen are mature than yours at
eighteen so maturity level differs and
act moreover there are exceptions in
humanity everywhere what happens point
number one the youngest you know Nobel
Peace Prize winner
the endless medical surgeon in the world
is fourteen years old who gave a great
ten who get her a giver
you know degree for grade 12 who gave
her a medical degree but she became a
surgeon at the age of fourteen how she's
an exception so you will always have
exceptions in the society so I shadowed
your love on her at her time if there
was a Nobel Peace Prize she would have
bagged all of them believe me she was
most matured woman of her time she was
the most intelligent and the most
memorizing capacity she was the scholar
of that time at that age of nine so she
picked up that and yes she was engaged
before that but Islam has two stages
when his engagement the other is actual
consummation of the marriage the
consummation of the marriage will not
take place unless and until the boy and
the girl both reach the age of puberty
they both agreed to it the parents agree
the society agrees the legality the law
agrees been sold out now when you have
someone who suffers this kind of abuse
which obviously the problem Hamid peace
be upon never had a girlfriend never had
relations outside of marriage he was
known as as
on the highest of moral grounds and
someone who suffers from that obviously
there's trauma they're traumatized their
whole life you don't you have any signs
of trauma and this woman yes definitely
sheet and Prophet Mohammed died after 10
years of the marriage and she lived for
a lot longer than that and she has never
complained she said he was the best
husband that I could ever imagine you
mention she was a scholar she was a
scholar in her own right and she was the
teacher for many of the great scholars
of the time and she never complained
moreover she was the one who propagated
the family relations between Prophet
Muhammad and her from that is all the
Muslims across the world pick up the
issues of family marriage and how to
deal with each other with love and
affection it's all through mother Asia
I shall be Ilana that's what shows that
she was more happier than anyone else in
the world you gave a good example you
just turn on many of these TV talk shows
and many of you mention a young girl at
and it's not even a marriage these are
just young kids coming together at 10:11
having heaven illicit sex and whatnot
it's sex education at young age for what
so that they can have a safe sex that's
what Islam sighs have everything in
legal bounding have everything in
discipline not loose not being used or
misused by each other so marriage only
protects the rights
that's why Islam allows marriage at an
early age because that's their freedom
you want to have sex what happens here
you have you know people go and have sex
by themselves at any age so Islam says
instead of doing it at any age you
better do it in a legal legal bond you
know people under 18 how many of up to
18 would not have sex in this community
today very few if everyone's having it
already what's the point of stopping
them from marrying them so Islam says
give the rights so that's another point
we covered I mean you can go on and
spend on this as time is short but now
the thing we want to see okay we covered
a few points at the end of the day how
does someone university student you can
see a lot of times the Muslims get
emotional yes and they don't end up
doing much good with their emotions they
end up doing more harm yeah point number
one Muslims are a very emotional
community as is any other community I'm
coming from Australia we have too
emotional I tell you what I don't have
we don't have time to get into
Australian culture but we'll come back
to it sometime point number two as a
Muslim you need to understand you're not
just representing yourself you're
representing Islam you're representing
Prophet Muhammad you're representing the
word of Allah
ALPA and so you got to behave
accordingly and the time of Prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him they were
torturing below the alarm
what he Prophet Muhammad do he did not
go and emotionally abuse the owner he
did not go and fight back what did he do
he use the law of the time and he asked
Boubacar to go and legally free Bilal so
what we should be doing today is legally
in America I can assure you the justice
system is very correct in Australia
recently there were three boys were
caught into terrorism but the judge said
there's no evidence go back home just
two days ago it just shows the justice
system we still have hope in it so when
you have hope in it you can actually go
and complain and get the police do the
job you don't have to jump on them and
react emotionally to that second way
what do you do is you give down to the
people you inform them about the truth
point number three how do you do that
how do you do at times when someone's
not ready to listen right Allah says in
the Quran when people are arguing for no
reason just say peace and leave walk
away so the best for you is to do that
at such situations in my chef I said you
there's no point of arguing with someone
who's who has lost his mentality who is
who's foolish and is a protein stupid
he said I've always lost a debate with a
foolish one so you just better give it
away at the time come back another time
and give the communication and give the
dialogue and do the dollars that would
at the end of the video we'll see right
here we'll go to this clip religion hey
just stole our book got just stole our
book
hey give us our book back now he doesn't
call for one hey leave him alone
it's got junk we see instead of giving
the Dawa instead of trying to recently
be I have a nice reasonable dialogue
with these people and at the end of it
doesn't work really peacefully then
that's taking the steel in the book yep
let's show when you take away the book
at least pay for it you know yeah that's
why you just you legally have taken the
book away
but anyway see I can understand the
reason for that and obviously you know
if someone's burning the Bible for
example I can show you some Christians
would all be list really and save it
that's yeah you wanna take it if
someone's burning the American
Constitution someone's going to snatch
it and take it away because emotionally
they're attached to it but the best way
to do at that time is legally call the
police for that and let them deal with
it and you better communicate with them
in a rational manner if they're not
ready to listen leave at that time
because there's no point of discussing
with a hateful person at the time but
when he comes down at a later time you
better approach and then dialogue with
that what would you say the last few
minutes to an individual like this you
know the leader of this group or any of
what what would you say my message to
these you know people hate hate people
fooled up hey fill of hate I'll say to
them I'll say this first to us to
ourselves as Nelson Mandela said he said
no one's born with hate they have been
taught to hate so they can be taught to
love so let's go for that and try to
teach them love
what would my response be to people like
these who are leading organizations or
groups like this who create hate I go
back to them and I say you are only
abusing your own teachings you are
actually becoming a disgrace for your
own religion so if you truly want to
have a cause and you want to put your
religion forward follow the religion and
the religion says to love people love
your neighbor follow Jesus if you want
to propagate Jesus otherwise you're only
becoming a disgrace in the name of Jesus
hope that responds to left thank you so
much we're out of time we look forward
to having you back again and Zack away
yeah it's an opportunity you think you
see something and thank you for tuning
in to the D show now we know those
fanatics they don't represent the true
loving Christians we know that just as
those people that the media is
expounding like they represent Muslims
24/7 doing some extreme things and
pumping you up they don't represent
Islam so let's us the rational thinking
people the people with the good hearts
go ahead and create a nice atmosphere
that we can go ahead and live in and we
can have a nice dialogue that we can go
ahead and even if we don't agree we can
agree to different disagree in a nice
peaceful way and not let people like
this dictate to us now what our religion
is so we hope that you got to benefit
from this and for the Muslims out there
don't get provoked learn your Dean this
Dean is a Dean of intellect based on
proof and evidence and now you can go
ahead and communicate the message in the
best most peaceful way using what the
Creator has given you but if you don't
know it and then you just result on
emotion you don't do any good for
yourself for the Dean or anybody
subscribe if you haven't already and
come back here to the Dean show every
week until next time peace be with you
please subscribe to the DCO follow us on
our official Facebook and Twitter pages
in the links below
please also help support the D show by
making a donation in the link below
[Music]